Ich sehe deine Waveform, ich sehe, es ist zu lang, schick doch eine kürzere Version. Ich sehe deine Waveform und merk es, dass sie nicht, ich liebe dich, doch du bist nichts für Florentin Lateiniensis. Okay. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser fantastischen neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast Ufo gegen mir. DPU, das Podcast Ufo. DPU mir gegenüber sitzt der unvergleichliche, unverwechselbare, nein, stimmt nicht, du wurdest schon ein paar Mal verwechselt, können wir gleich darüber reden. Mit jemandem aus der Blue Man Group. Das stimmt. Es ist Stefan Tietze. Hallo, und gegenüber von mir sitzt der wirklich Unverwechselbare, er sieht so eigenartig aus, also so wirklich so merkwürdig speziell, dass es gar keine Grundlage gibt, in dem zu verwechseln.
Ich glaube, die Zuhörer mögen das gar nicht, wenn das am Anfang.
Stefan, wollte ich fast sagen, Florentin.
Hallo, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid und vielen Dank an diesen kleinen Türöffner von Julian, der, er hat geschrieben, er ist in Spanien durch die Gassen galoppiert und hat plötzlich diesen Hit gehört. Vor den Cafés hat er diesen Hit gehört. Anscheinend wurde dein kurzes Intermezzo im Podcast in Spanien zu einem Schlagerhit geworden. Also das war eine Frage der Zeit, bis ich in Spanien zum Schlagerstar werde. Ich dachte ja auch schon, als ich nach Peru gereist bin, dass ich in Südamerika erkannt werde. Also man, ich weiss nicht, ist das ein Film oder so, oder so eine bekannte Trope?
Ich muss die ganze Zeit darüber lachen dass mich die ganze zeit ist nicht passiert aber ich fand die vorstellung so lustig trotzdem darüber dass ich muss und du musst dir die ganze drüber lachen was ich mir ausgedacht was alle dachten auch vielleicht ist die höhe die gerade zu schaffen macht ich habe die ganze zeit darüber gelacht dass ich verwechsel jemanden, den sie kennen, aus so einer, ich weiß nicht, ist irgend so ein Gringo aus so einer Werbung. Ach so, ja, ja, genau. Dann kommt da, dass ich ein Star bin. Dass die Leute dich für den Brad Pitt halten oder sowas. Brad Pitt. Brad Pitt halten und dann, sie sind doch Brad Pitt. Ah, Geis, Geis, Geis. Also, Brad Pitt? Nee, Pip. Nee, Pip. Und dann so ein Wider-Typ, der so ganz komischer Der ist der Brad Pitt Spaniens, Brad Pip. Das war klar. Vielen Dank an Julian für das Intro, dass uns hier heute rein, dass uns so ein bisschen den Sand gestreut hat, damit wir hier trocken und sicher ankommen im Podcast-Land. Die Idee dieses kleinen Bits, dieser kleinen Einlage, dieser gesangliche Natur. Ich hab eigentlich keine Frage gestellt. Ich hab eigentlich keine Frage gestellt. War ja, dass Intros kommen, mehr Intros kommen. Ja. Und auf eine Art habe ich damit ja Erfolg gehabt. Auf eine Art hast du Erfolg gehabt, wir haben tatsächlich viele Intros bekommen diese Woche, allerdings Qualität runter. Ohohohoho das passiert ich sage einfach mal nur für alle füchse da draußen die nächsten zehn folgen werden auch mit ki intros gespickt sein ihr könnt ja vielleicht in den den Kommentaren dann diskutieren, bei welcher Folge das war, falls ihr wirklich gar nichts anderes zu tun habt. Also falls euer Kalender wirklich gähnend leer ist und ihr noch irgendwas sucht, was ihr machen könnt, dann dachte ich mir, könnt ihr ja vielleicht das KI-Quiz spielen, das nochmal vergleichen, vielleicht mit Freunden zusammen sein. Es ist nicht boring, es ist so, es ist nicht jeder hat so ein aufregendes Leben wie du, Stefan, nicht jeder hat so ein aufregendes Leben. Für viele Leute ist es wirklich das Highlight der Woche und das möchte ich denen auch nicht nehmen. Deswegen spielt gerne das KI-Spiel, setzt euch zusammen mit Freunden und Bekannten und kommentiert dann gerne im Reddit. Es wäre so ein Ravensburger schönes, designtes Spiel. Es ist einfach nur... Es klickt unsere Folge möglichst oft an. War das Intro jetzt KI oder nicht? War das Intro das eines Amateurmusikers oder das einer Amateur-KI? Das ist die Frage... Eines schlechten Musikers oder einer schlechten KI? Also, hmm, kann man jetzt natürlich vergleichen. Ist der beste Musiker schlechter als die schlechteste KI oder andersrum?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich bin ein großer Fan, ich habe einen absoluten Lieblingsfilm, man kann ja mal Filme raussagen jetzt im Jahreswechsel. Hau mal einen Film raus.
Und zwar Boogie Nights, liebe ich ja, beste Film aller Zeiten für mich. Und da ist er die Idee, ein junger Pornodarsteller, verdient sehr viel Geld, ist der große Star in seiner neuen Branche und ist dann so ein bisschen durch sein Stardom wird er dann dazu veranlasst, auch andere Sachen zu machen. Zum Beispiel will er dann ein Album aufnehmen und sitzt dann im Studio und nimmt halt sehr, sehr schlecht Musik auf. Und so ein bisschen beobachte ich das jetzt auch immer bei Influencern auf Instagram. Und es war wirklich, gestern habe ich das eins zu eins gesehen. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, wer, dann schreit dem nachher. Aber ein männlicher Influencer, der vor allem so modelt und halt gut aussieht und damit Geld verdient, hat jetzt ersternt sich ins Studio und singt und es ist halt wirklich wie eine Paul Thomas Anderson-Sz Er stellt sich in ein Studio und singt dann ganz, ja, schief, aber sehr... Aber so emotional. Ja, aber so mega emotional, hängt er oben mit dem Mikrofon und sagt, break, break, break my heart, break, break und dann alle so im Studio, mega geil, yes. Ja, genau so, ey, richtig gut, ey, super geil, mega gut. Ah, ich hab noch eine Idee, nach dem Break, Break my Heart kommt noch so ein Yeah! Okay, ja, find ich cool. Vielleicht schaust du mal, dass du die Töne triffst, wär auch mal eine Variante. Ja genau, das wünschst man sich. Also vielleicht wär das mal was. Aber so jemand, man wünscht sich so einen Super-Villain. Ja, ja, so einen wirklich älteren, kurz vor der Rente stehenden Producer, der nichts zu verlieren hat, der irgendwie schon mit Michael Jackson gearbeitet hat und der Blue Man Group und der einfach sagt, naja, das machen wir auch nochmal. Das machen wir nochmal richtig, oder? Wollen wir es einfach sein lassen jetzt? Soll ich es direkt löschen oder wollen wir es später nochmal raus mit dem Löschen? Genau, wollen wir direkt die Session abbrechen, weil ihr nicht singen könnt oder wollen wir nochmal nochmal? Und ich wünschte mir ja fast so, dass die Kamera, die es gefilmt hat, so schwenkt zu jemandem, der so Gym-mäßig wie The Office in die Kamera guckt und dann so die Luft reinzieht und denkt, holy shit, und das jetzt 30 Tage? Aber die gibt es nicht, diese Supervillens, die du dir wünschst, völlig zu Recht gibt es nicht in diesem Studio. Da sind nur Leute, die den hypen und die das mehr geil finden, wahrscheinlich Geld verdienen, auch damit oder gleich auch noch singen. Ja, ja, das steht wahrscheinlich auch im Vertrag mit dem Tonsteil dabei steht dabei wollen sie konstruktive kritik oder wollen wir sie ausschliesslich loben das
würde noch mal 200 euro extra kosten und dann sagen wir alles was sie machen ist gut das ist
doch schön okay vielleicht noch einmal im takt wenn es geht aber dann aber jetzt inzwischen auch
mit dem neuen mit der neuesten technik, haben wir im Intro auch gerade gehört, man hat mich da gerade gezogen. Mit Out-of-Tune und Melodyne. Ach, sehr fein. Du hast ein bisschen traurig geguckt während des Intro-Liefs. War das für dich ein Punkt, dass man dann ... Nee, weil ich hab ja Perfect Pitch. Weil ich hab ja Perfect Pitch. Okay, aber trotzdem musste ja noch mal nachkorrigiert werden anscheinend. Ja genau, nee, ich glaub, weil sein Midi-Keyboard war halt dazwischen. Das war verstischen, mikrotonal. Ah, sein Midi-Keyboard war verstimmt und dann musste er dich anpassen. Ja, also mich eher anpassen, weil er dich richtig anpassen kann. Ich finde das aber ein bisschen schwierig mit diesem Klischee von wegen, ah, man ist erfolglos, man hat nichts mehr in seiner Karriere und nimmt ein Album auf, weil ich will eines Tages auch ein Album aufnehmen. Und ich versuche jetzt natürlich zu überlegen, wie kann man das schon irgendwie, naja, ankündigen, ohne in diese Falle zu fallen. Also muss man es dann ironisch sprechen und sagen, jetzt kommt auch noch das dumme Album mit zwölf nichtssagenden Tracks. Und jetzt auch noch das Album? Fragezeichen, das wäre ein Titel. Ach, ich wusste gar nicht, dass der Musik macht, so was, so heißt dann das Album oder sowas in der Richtung. Aber es ist natürlich schon. Oder dieses Podcast-Äquivalent, muss es noch ein Musikalbum geben. Ja, ja, genau, ja. Heute hat doch jeder ein Album. Heute macht doch jeder Musik. Ja, ja, aber es scheint eine Kunstform zu sein, auf die sich jeder einigen kann, ne, also die wenigsten sagen dann, ich mach, ich schreib ein Ballett oder so, ich schreib ein Theaterstück, sondern auf Musik kannst du jeder einigen, wahrscheinlich weil die Industrie auch so krass ist, du sagst nur, übrigens, ich würde
gerne ein Album schreiben und dann kann man
alles für dir aus der Hand nehmen, wohingegen
wenn du jetzt wirklich so einen dreiteiligen
Roman über den
russischen Befreiungskrieg machst, wirklich
Moskau, die Gassen,
wenn du da wirklich machst, dann musst du dich
da, glaube ich, nicht investieren.
Warum sagst du die Gassen, hast du so laut
auch gesagt und so aggressiv? Na ja, da ist viel passiert in den Gassen. Ja, aber warum musst du das jetzt? In Moskauer Gassen. Ja, okay, ich verstehe, dass da in den Moskauer Gassen viel los ist, von dem wir gar keine Ahnung haben, von dem wir nicht mal trinken können. Von dem wir uns nicht mal vorstellen können, was da passiert ist. Warum zitzt du, als warst du da gewesen? Warst du da gewesen, als es passiert ist? Die Bücher berühren mich. Die Bücher berühren
mich. Ich glaube, es ist deswegen so, weil Musik zum einen, anders als Bücher lesen oder so, eine
Kunstform ist, die alle berührt im Leben, mit der alle was zu tun haben. Also alle haben sehr früh
sind Musik ausgesetzt. So und deswegen glaube ich, wenn die dann,
keine Ahnung, modeln und bekannt werden,
viel Geld haben, ist
der Kunst zu machen, aus Grund von
was auch immer, narzisstischen Selbstverwirklichungsgründen,
was auch immer, muss auch nicht narzisstisch sein, aber einfach
aus Bock, was von sich in die Welt zu setzen,
ist, glaube ich, die einfachste Kunstform,
weil die ja auch dafür
da ist, selbst Taylor Swift
oder sowas, bucht ja Sessions bei diesen ganzen schwedischen krassen Produzenten, hängt dann mit denen tagelang im Studio und die machen schon was Gutes, die kann ja auch Songs schreiben, aber selbst die ist ja dann da und bucht und die ganze Industrie ist ja dafür da, dass Leute wie dieses Model, was sehr viel Geld hat, dann in diese Studios geht, denen sehr viel Geld gibt, und dann hast du diese Infrastruktur aus Producern und Beatproduzenten um die herum und es läuft schon. Wenn du ein Buch schreiben willst, meine epische Reihe Der Herr der Lage, die Trilogie. Mit witzigen Anekdoten aus dem Alltag, trotzdem tausend Seiten lang. ist ein richtiger Schinken, mit was sich am Supermarkt erlebt hat. Ist ein Herr der Ringe-artiger Epos, aber halt Herr der Lage. Ja, okay. Und es passiert nicht so viel. Das ist du auf der Suche nach einer neuen Wohnung. Aber es ist episch, wirklich über hunderte Kapitel hinaus. Nee, ich bin immer, ist Herr der Lage. Also man denkt, ah, jetzt geht er aufs Abenteuer. Ach, krass, jetzt kommt das Brief vom Finanzamt Finanzamt, call to action, jetzt geht's los. Ich hab schon gelegelt.
Ach so, ich hab's schon. Ich hab schon bezahlt vorher. Ich hab schon bezahlt.
Und die haben sich fälschlicherweise gemeldet. Aber gut, die haben sich ein bisschen spät gemeldet, aber ich bin immer Herr der Lage. Okay, du kommst in einem Auto, Strafzettel und sagst, nee, nee, hier ist jetzt zwischen 12 und 13, ist ja hier nochmal frei wegen dem Keimhaus. Ach ja, klar, nee, okay. Schönen Weihnachten, schöne Weihnachten. Weihnachten. Aber ja, Musik ist natürlich auch ein unendlicher neuer Fluss nötig, Du brauchst immer neue Musik, es braucht immer neue Musik, jeden Monat neue Songs, außer zu Weihnachten. Das gesamte Jahr sagt man, wir brauchen neue Hits, neue Trends, neue Charts, die Radioredaktionen wühlen, dass sie nicht ständig die gleichen Songs brauchen, außer drei Monate im Jahr, da spielt man die gleichen vier Songs ununterbrochen konstant. Da ist dann die Logik komplett umgedreht, da ist dann auf gar keinen Fall was Neues. Ja, das ist crazy. Auch es wird ja seit Jahren versucht, den neuen Weihnachtssitz zu schreiben. Schafft niemand. Ja, ja, die sitzen alle dran, Shosokowitsch, Ralf Bartels, alle sitzen da und sagen, Mensch, Klingelingeling, die Glocken spielen, wir haben Klingelingeling, die Glocken, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, schmeiß nochmal nochmal alles weg. Ich finde den Anfang gut. Schmeiß nochmal alles weg. Klingelingeling, die Glocken singen. Die Englein singen. Also die Glöckchen klingen, die Englein singen. Klingelingeling, die Glöckchen klingen. Klingelingeling, die Englein singen. Das ist wieder dein Ohio. Fantastisch. Das ist dein Ohio-Jingle, den du überall versuchst einzubauen. Ohio! Das hat Stefan mal seine Solokarriere versucht aufzunehmen mit einem... Ohio! Klingelingeling, die Döckchen klingen. Klingelingeling, die Engle singen. Es ist ein angenehm kurzer Weihnachtssong, damit du den direkt nochmal abspielen kannst, einfach konstant und immer wieder. Es klingt wie so ein Anrufer, so ein Jamba-Spa-Abo-Anruf. Ja, stimmt. Jamba? Jamba, Jamba, Samba, Samba, Samba, Jamba. Jamba? Nee, du kannst es nicht so sagen. Haben wir nicht alle falsch? Jamba! Wir haben alle falsch Jamba gesagt. Es hieß die ganze Zeit Jamba? Das weiß ich nicht. Nein, das war das Jamba-Spar-Ammo. Das muss man schon für die Historie festhalten. Falls Historiker in 100 Jahren noch mal zurückgucken, was war denn da los, das hat man schon Jamba ausgesprochen. Aber das ist tatsächlich ... Haben dies auch Jamba ausgesprochen? Es gibt ja so ein paar Sachen, wo man sich entschieden hat, Dinge falsch auszusprechen. Wie Miracle Whip. Weißt du also... Statt Whip. Statt Miracle Whip. Das ist ja die wundersame Whip. Miracle Whip. Miracle Whip. Aber es ist eigentlich, alle sagen Miracle Whip. Oh Stefan, du bist so geil. Du hast immer diese kleinen Nuggets. Du hast immer noch irgendwie so einen Schokobon in der Tasche. Diese Podcast-Nuggets. Du hast immer noch so einen Schokobon in der Tasche. Bei dir, du ziehst, wenn jemand sagt, ich habe gerade irgendwie ein Hüngerchen, ziehst du immer noch mal einen Toffee-Fee aus der Tasche. Du hast immer noch mal was dabei. Für die Kinder am Spielplatz. Immer noch einen von meiner Körperwärme flüssiges Schokobon. Ja, nimm doch mal. Ach so, nee, danke. Nimm. Ich soll nichts annehmen von Podcastern. Mein Vater hat gesagt, ich darf keine Süßigkeiten von Podcastern annehmen. Weißt du, warum es Frucht-Tiger heisst? Ach nein. Wegen Frucht-Tiger. Wegen Frucht-Tiger. Hier, nimm das Bonbon. Nein, danke. Und dann dreht er sich kurz weg, das Kind, und dann dreht er sich um und ist weg, Podcaster ist weg. The Podcaster. The Podcatcher. The Podcatcher. Oh Gott, oh Gott. Das ist auch mal eine Serie von Podcastern, die dann immer ihre Situation selber herbeiführen, sozusagen. Witzige Anekdoten aus dem Alltag, aber dann selber herbeiführen, indem sie irgendwie mit dem Auto irgendwie so einen Baum umfahren, um dann zu sagen, oh, ich bin, der Krankenwagen kam zu spät oder sowas. Genau, das ist genau das Gleiche. The Podcatcher, ist ja, ist die Podcatcher nicht einfach eine App, mit der man Podcast hören kann? Ja, es ist eine allgemeine Bezeichnung für verschiedene Apps, die den RSS-Feed sozusagen bekommen und dann die Folgen runterladen für dich, Stefan. Ach, das ist der Überbegriff. Das funktioniert ein Podcast. Ich finde es erstaunlich, dass wir seit 389 Folgen Podcast machen und Stefan wirklich mit grossen Augen. Was? Ach, das wird aufgenommen? Da merkt man mal wieder, wie Stefan keine Ahnung hat, was hier passiert. Und wer hier seit 389 Folgen die Folgen hochlädt und sich mit der ganzen Technik beschäftigt und Stefan einfach nur so, hä, was ist der, nee, Stefan, du musst ins Mikrofon reden. Das stimmt gerade, ja, gerade hing mein Mikrofon ganz woanders. Nein, du musst ins Mikrofon sprechen, das Mikrofon oben. Ach so, ist, ach so, wir haben Wachnum dabei. Aber ich habe gerade wirklich das Mikrofon hinter mir und ich habe mich hingesetzt und wollte mit dir reden und dann hast du gesagt, Stefan, du musst ins Mikrofon. Ich habe mich ganz gewundert, warum ich leise bin. Aber es sind manchmal diese lustigen kleinen Momente, wo man neben sich. Die passieren einfach. Diese Ungeschicke des Alltags. Es ist aber trotzdem, ich bemerke, dass bei vielen Dingen, die ich seit Jahren mache, aber schlicht nicht besser werde. Also normalerweise denkt man ja, wenn du was oft machst, wirst du irgendwann besser. Ja, ist das jetzt eine Kritik an meinem Podcast-Fähigkeit? Ja, ein bisschen schon, ein bisschen schon. Dafür, dass wir zehn Jahre machen, sind wir extrem ähnlich. Schlecht. Schlecht noch wie am Anfang. Aber was wolltest du gerade sagen? Ja, zum Beispiel so Podcast schneiden oder so. Da dachte ich mir am Anfang, boah, das das fällt mir echt schwer, das zu mischen, den Ton anzupassen, dass wir beide gleich laut sind. Das fällt mir sehr schwer. Da dachte ich, naja, da kommt man rein. 400 Folgen später, nein, genau die gleichen Probleme, ich höre nichts. Wenn du mir zwei Geräusche gibst und fragst, welches ist lauter, ich würde es nicht wissen. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Die ersten Folgen habe ich noch sehr doll geschnitten. Wir machen mal ein bisschen so einen Jahresrückblick, whatever, Podcastrückblick. Die ersten Folgen waren wirklich ein Flickenteppich. Da wurden teilweise Enden von Anekdoten nach vorne geschoben, damit es ... Um das so ein bisschen Tarantino-esk, antichronologisch zu erzählen, haben wir uns verkünstelt hier. Nee, aber um da die Prämisse klarer zu setzen und dann eine Pause, damit das Timing für die Punchline besser sitzt. Echt? Inzwischen, klar, hast du jemals zu sehen? Das wusste ich gar nicht. Doch, da habe ich richtig viel rumgeschnitten. Ich dachte, du hast nur deine Ams und deine Ams rausgeschnitten und deine verschiedenen, ja sagen wir mal, verfassungsfeindlichen Tiraden rausgeschnitten. Ja, stimmt voll. Wo du am Ende noch mal nachgeguckt hast im Gesetzbuch und gemerkt hast, ach ja, jetzt. Wenn dir ganz laut das auftritt, hört ihr noch hinten das Verfassungsbuch.
Und dann so ein
Oh shit!
Und dann halt den krassen Schnitt.
Wir können aber tatsächlich gerne diese Situation mal kurz nehmen,
um einen kleinen Rückblick zu machen, denn
Post aus der Reddit-Redaktion
Post aus der Reddit-Einsendung. Und zwar gibt es in unserem fantastischen Reddit Das Podcast-Ufo seit langem eine tolle Aktion. Und zwar wird da das Podcast-Ufo-Alphabet aufgeschrieben, also zu jedem Buchstaben des Alphabets. Ein Begriff aus der Podcast-Ufo-Geschichte. und dann durften die ganzen Hörerinnen und Hörer da abstimmen, was für sie für jeweiliges den Buchstaben des Alphabets ein Begriff aus der Podcast-Uvo-Geschichte und dann durften die ganzen Hörerinnen und Hörer da abstimmen, was für sie, für jeweiliges den Buchstaben ein passendes Wort ist. Und jetzt ist die Liste fast vollständig, vollständig, ich glaube, wir können das mal so angehen. Und für alle, die jetzt nicht im Reddit aktiv sind, können wir das ja so mal ein bisschen mit begleiten. Da gab es viel Streit, also zu jedem einzelnen Buchstaben gab es wahnsinnig viel streit und wir können das ganze mal so ein bisschen durchgehen also meine angst als es aufkam diese idee ich fand die ganz toll aber meine angst war als ob wir jetzt sehen wir nicht seit vier und folgen die gleichen zehn anekdoten und das alphabet hat wie viele buchstaben 900 das geht doch nicht hinhauen. Und dann kommt ja auch irgendwann X und Q und sowas. Forget it. Forget it. Aber die Hörerinnen und Hörer haben ein ganz tolles Gedächtnis und haben ganz tolle Ideen gehabt. Und es ist tatsächlich voll. Also zu Z gibt es noch nichts, aber die Vorschläge unten sind auch schon toll. Also ja, vielen, vielen Dank und ich bin auch ein bisschen stolz, dass wir so viel Buchstaben. Ja, dass wir schon ein komplettes Alphabet vollgekriegt haben in 400 Folgen. Wir können ja mal anfangen mit A, ich glaube, da war es relativ einstimmig, natürlich unsere liebgewonnene Rubrik beziehungsweise. Unvergessene Rubrik. Ich würde sagen, vergessene und auch beerdigte Rubrik.
Genau, und vergessene Rubrik, nicht unvergessen.
Entschuldigung, da war jetzt ganz wichtig.
Und zwar ist es natürlich Antenne Afrika.
Es ist Antenne Afrika, wo wir, glaube ich, von den 55 Ländern Afrikas drei geschafft haben oder so.
Das waren natürlich sechs am Ende.
So viel, dass ich dieses Ich-Pack-her-mein-Kofferspiel nicht mehr hinbekommen habe.
Und irgendwann kann ich jetzt ja mal zugeben, weil wir in dieser Behind-the-Scenes artigen Rubrik sind, mir aufgeschrieben haben, bei meinem Notes-Ding, um gegen dich zu gewinnen. Genau, ich habe immer versucht, das noch aus dem Gedächtnis zu machen und Stefan einfach gecheatet, einfach betrogen, einfach abgelesen. Weil wir immer, weiss ich nicht, weil der zehnminütige Beiträge kommen, die wir teilweise ans Ende der Folge schneiden mussten, weil es halt journalistisch cool war, aber zu lang für einen Comedy-Haha, Deckenlampen, das strahlen mir ins Gesicht, was auch immer, Anekdoten, ich sitze in der Badewanne und eine Gurke fällt mir ins Wasser, das passt halt nicht rein. Und dann ist es wie respektlos, es ist nicht zu wissen, aber es ist auch schwierig, sich das zu merken. Ja, wir wollten eigentlich alle Länder Afrikas einmal durchgehen. Es gibt auch einen guten Pofopedia-Artikel dazu, wo ihr nochmal genau sehen könnt, welche Länder wir gemacht haben und welche nicht. Kontroverse, weil es gab tatsächlich, glaube ich, bei dem Beitrag von Burkina Faso oder so, der war so lang, dass wir dann nur die ersten paar Minuten in der Folge gespielt haben und den Rest hinten dran gehängt haben. Und da wurden anscheinend irgendwelche Verschwörungstheorien verbreitet, wo Leute sich beschwert haben.
Und ich das überhaupt nicht verstanden habe, aber mir am Ende gedacht habe, das ist Afrika, Leute.
Ich meine, da gab es irgendwelche, glaube ich, dass irgendjemand von irgendjemandem ermordet wurde,
was bis heute aber ungeklärt ist und wo irgendwie verschiedene politische Kräfte versuchen, das für sich zu instrumentalisieren. Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, alles vergessen. Okay. Also das war jetzt das offizielle Statement, wir distanzieren uns von Burkina Faso. Oh, vom Land Burkina Faso? Ja. Ich glaube, das macht es nicht besser, aber okay. Okay, Antenafrika, ich mochte die Rubrik immer sehr. Keine Ahnung, es gibt aber auch jetzt nicht so viele Hörer und Hörer, glaube ich, noch in anderen Ländern. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir noch ein paar Beiträge in der Schlange haben.
Extrem unbeliebte Rubrik, muss man sagen. Von vielen, naja, es gibt deswegen, viele von euch wissen wahrscheinlich gar nicht, was das ist. B, natürlich die unvergessene Geschichte Stephans Boosted Board. Es gab eine Zeit, da war Stephan geboosted. Nicht nur haben wir uns am Anfang sehr geboosted mit Boostern, sondern Stephan hat dann individuell nochmal gesagt. Boosting war ein grosses Thema. Aber können wir auch nur rückblickend nur raten, wenn wir so bei TikTok mal irgendwann so einen Channel machen, wo wir sagen, hey, ihr wollt einen Podcast an den Start bekommen, hier sind fünf Tipps, die ihr gebrauchen könnt. Erstens, boosted. Ja, boosted euch. Also wenn uns eins geholfen hat, dann die Booster Energy Drinks am Anfang und Boosted Board. Ich kann jetzt ja mal hier für unsere Patreon-Subscriber, die uns immer sehen können, die Narben zeigen, denn ich hab hier, sieht man jetzt auch nicht so gut wahrscheinlich in dem Licht, aber man sieht immer noch meine... Ja, super, aber man sieht immer noch die Boosted Board Narbe. Boosted Narbe eigentlich. Und hier sieht man immer noch meine ... Das ist sehr unbeeindruckend, Stefan. Ja, super unbeeindruckend. Aber man sieht immer noch die Boosted-Board-Narbe. Boosted-Narbe eigentlich. Und hier sieht man immer noch meine ... Ui! Die ist wiederum sehr beeindruckend. Oh, da kommen wir bei uns beim S dazu. Schlüsselbein-Narbe. Ah ja, guck mal. Ui. Ist es wirklich S? Ne, guck mal nicht. Ist es nicht. Tatsächlich, die ist immer noch gross zu sehen. Ja, ma, das, finde ich, macht dich jetzt ganz hot. Hot eigentlich, ne, mit deinen Narben und du kannst, dein Körper erzählt Geschichten. Hör mal, er erzählt eine Geschichte. Stefan scheitert bei motorisierten E-Mobilität. Das ist eigentlich die Geschichte. Ja, okay, das ist die Geschichte. Aber trotzdem, dein Körper erzählt eine Geschichte. Mein Körper erzählt Übergewicht. So, mein Körper erzählt Waffel einmal. Das ist ja auch keine super gute Geschichte. Mein Körper erzählt, weil ich habe so Angst vor diesen Runden, vor diesen Flaschendrehen artigen Runden, die es ja immer gibt mit, zeigt mal euren coolsten Narben und dann kommt irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Joey aus Australien, zeigt dann seine ganzen Hai-Bisse und ich zeige halt 19 Narben und alle immer, krass, noch eine, wann hört das endlich auf? Wann ist Joey wieder dran? Wann soll Joey sich das Shirt ausziehen? Aber ich habe noch 19 Narben, aber alle, und es wird auch nicht spannender, weil alle kommen von E-Mobilität. Du bist mit dem Roller gestürzt, du bist mit dem Boosted Board gestürzt. Wo ist das Boosted Board heute? Können wir da mal kurz dazuschreiben? Ja, habe verkauft, bei Ebay. Mit Blut noch dran, mit Blut an den Rädern kleben.
Ja, mit frischem Blut habe ich das inzwischen verkauft bei Ebay.
Und weißt du, wie es dem neuen Besitzer geht?
Nein, okay. Die Firma ist mittlerweile auch pleite.
Ach ja.
Tatsächlich, ich habe das ja noch bei How to Sell Drugs reingeschrieben, Boosted Board, damit die Firma noch eins kostenlos bekommt und sowas.
Da gab sie schon noch. Inzwischen gibt
sie gar nicht mehr, diese Firma.
Komplett pleite. Kannst du dir vorstellen,
warum?
Weil die Arschteuer waren und alle
sterben? Oder weil die Leute stürzen mit diesen
Geräten? Weil alle Kunden tot sind?
Unsere Kunden sterben, wir fliegen.
Wieso, weil die so alt sind? Nein, weil die
sind 25 und stürzen. Naja gut, die sind alle tot. C.
Busted Board auf jeden Fall abgeschlossen. C, natürlich Christina Stürmer, unsere Lieblings-Popsängerin, die tatsächlich vor kurzem erst noch einen neuen Post rausgehauen hat auf Instagram, wo sie nochmal gesagt hat, was war ihre Lieblingstextseile ihres gesamten Oeuvres und sie hat natürlich aus dem Song Ich lebe die unvergessene Textseile genannt, Du bist die Welt, wo Schattenlicht gefangen hält. Und das ist ganz interessant, weil das ist genau die Textseile. Da haben wir uns ja darin festgehangen. Genau, das ist genau die Textseile, wo es in verschiedenen Versionen von Ich lebe, die eine Version ist, Du bist die Welt, wo Schattenlicht gefangen hält, aber in einer anderen Version, und das ist keine Interpretation, das ist wirklich so, singt sie, Du bist die Welt, die Schattenlicht gefangen hält. Hört euch das gerne auf Spotify an. Ist Schattenlicht nicht das Pferd von Gandalf? Das ist Schattenfell, aber es ist, keine Ahnung, vielleicht irgendeine Fanfic oder so, aber es ist, könnt ihr gerne euch auf Spotify mal anhören, es gibt wirklich zwei Versionen und ganz spannend, dass genau das die Zeile ist, die sie als Lieblingszeile dann postet, die sie ja anscheinend entweder mal falsch gesungen hat bei einer Liveaufnahme oder so, ich glaube das ist die Liveaufnahme, oder wo sie irgendwann mal ein anderer Textteil im Kopf hatte. Irgend kopf hatte irgendwas ist da noch als ich glaube es als künstler baut man ja manchmal so geheime spuren ein in seine in seinem werk die von den hörern gefunden werden können oder oder nach jahren unentdeckt bleiben folge zwölf folge zwölf minute 34 startpunkt dasreißig, Startpunkt, das ist der Startpunkt aber nur, hört an nicht auf zu suchen, es geht noch weiter, das Rätsel versteckt sich überall und deswegen ganz interessant, dass es da letztens erstmal noch einen Throwback gab zu dem tollen Song, Throw-Up. Genau, mal. Tuesday, Throw-Up. Throw-Up Tuesday. Nochmal eine kleine Erinnerung.
Ja, ja. weil Tuesday Throw-Up, Throw-Up Tuesday, noch mal eine kleine Erinnerung gehabt.
Ja, ja, mit Christina Stimme. Ich lebe, weil du mein Atem bist, bin müde, weil du mein Kissen bist, bin durstig, weil du das Wasser bist, du bist für mich mein zweites Ich.
Toll, toller Song.
Wo Schattenlicht gefangen hält, du bist das Geld, ich geb dich aus, es lohnt sich nicht. Wie ein Vampir. Oder so. Ich kipp dich aus wie ein Vampir, du bist der Tee, ich trink dich und dann vergess ich dich. Und auch die Kamera schwenkt zu dem Toningenieur. Du bist das Bild, mein Pinsel malt dich an und du bist der Toast, ich tost dich, bis du knusprig bist. Du bist das Ei, ich koch dich, bis du ganz hart bist. Du bist der Schnee, du fällst herunter, mir ist kalt. Du bist der Sturm, du wehst mich weg, ich glaub es nicht, ich lebe, weil du mein... Es ist ein toller Song, man kann ihn unendlich lang machen. Cool, wir sind erst bei C. Es geht weiter mit D für Dinosaurier. Dinosaurier, du musst aufpassen, dass sie dich nicht fressen. So oder so. Ist ein Klassiker auf jeden Fall. E sind natürlich die Aliens. Die Aliens. Die totbringenden Aliens. Die totbringenden Aliens. Auf E. Ey, wenn ihr gerade merkt, what the fuck is with those guys, ist es, warum ist der Podcast überhaupt bei Spotify zu hören, professionell, und es ist gerade die erste Folge, die ihr hört, The Down.
Ja, entschuldige.
Weil gerade wir lachen uns auch kaputt über Erinnerungen und so.
Ja, das stimmt. Wir dürfen auch mal zurückgucken und in Erinnerung schwächen.
Genau, nicht mehr nur nach vorne, wir gucken immer nach vorne.
Ja, wir schauen immer nur nach vorne.
Hinter uns können fiese Tiere, Dämonen, wilde, weiss ich nicht, Werbe, für seinen Seeminn, wir gucken mehr nach vorne. Wir gucken immer nach vorne. Ja, wir schauen immer nur nach vorne. Hinter uns können fiese Tiere, Dämonen, wilde, weiss ich nicht, Wölfe, sein Seemirn, ich gucke nur nach vorne. Die totbringenden Aliens begleitet uns auch noch ein bisschen weiter. Irgendwer hat mir mal geschickt, wie dieser Synchronsprecher heißt, den ich da vergeblich versuche nachzumachen, habe ich vergessen. G. Ja, oder F, Fehlkäufe. Hast du vielleicht direkt übersprungen. Fehlkäufe, natürlich der ganz alte Klassiker. Also das ist ja wirklich aus der allerersten Stunde. Stefan Tietze natürlich bekannt für seine Fehlkäufe. Was war der letzte Fehlkauf? Was hast du dir geholt? Gute Frage, ich habe jetzt gemerkt, ich habe gepiekt als Fehlkäufer, weil jetzt Dinge wie mein Stocksauberroboter, den ich mal als Fehlkauf deklariert hatte, auch verkauft hatte bei Ebay, habe ich mir jetzt wieder gekauft, einen neuen. Okay, der kreist schließlich, also das ist der zweite Fehlkauf. Nee, ich würde eher behaupten. Es gibt in dieser Reihe drei Fehlkäufe. Erst kaufst du ihn Fehl, dann kaufst ihn der, den du es verkauft hast, kaufst es nochmal Fehl und dann kaufst du ein drittes Mal Fe. Zurück, fehl, fehl, fehl. Drei Fehlkäufe. Nee, ich kaufe mir einen anderen, den man dann gebrauchen kann, um zu merken, ah, mein erster Fehlkauf war gar kein Fehlkauf, sondern in fact ein Kauf. Ah, ich verstehe, okay. Nee, ich habe mir jetzt einen Saug-Wisch-Roboter gekauft, der mein Leben tatsächlich vereinfacht, der kann saugen und wischen. Also sozusagen zwei in einem. Ein Saug- und Wisch-Roboter. Genau, und der kartografiert auch geil deine Wohnung, das ist auch cool. Und der ist sogar so clever, der, wenn er wogegen fährt, taucht auf der Karte, die er dann kartografiert, um dann danach die besseren Wege zu fahren, schreibt dahin, was er glaubt, was es ist, was da im Weg stand.
Und es ist ganz süss, weil das Fahrrad, was an meiner Wand steht, hält er für einen Stuhl, Klappstuhl, dann hält er so ein Instrument von mir für ein Kehrblech,
viele Schuhe hat er richtig erkannt, die liegen in der Wohnung wild rum, Stühle erkennt er als solche, eine kleine Stehlampe, hat er unten Sockel erkannt, also er fährt dann schön außenrum, er hat Sockel gesagt, eine Sockellampe und er hat recht, weil das ist eine Sockellampe und dann muss er außenrum eine Runde fahren, was natürlich für diese Geräte nicht so einfach ist. Und er ist so schlau, dass er hinter die meisten Dinge, die er findet, noch in Klammern schreibt, Fehlkauf. Sockel, Fehlkauf. Schlagzeug, Fehlkauf.
Kommentare. Soll ich das auf Ebay stellen? Nee, lass mal. findet noch in Klammern, schreibt Fehlkauf. Sockel, Fehlkauf. Schlagzeug, Fehlkauf.
Kommentare. Soll ich das auf Ebay stellen?
Nee, lass mal.
Hättest du billiger bekommen oder so.
Wo man immer denkt, ich will keine Kommentare von dir,
kleiner Roboter. Ich will, dass du
saugst. Genau, saug und wisch.
Und also nutzt du den auch privat?
Zum Saugen und Wischen?
Ja, also dass man abends alle einsam ist.
Achso, ja klar, weil wir saugen und wischen gemeinsam bis später in die Nacht. Stellst du dich manchmal auf den drauf und fährst rum damit? Klar, telefonieren, dann telefonieren wir jetzt auch. Das ist so ein Ding. Das ist schon gut. In so Business-Talks am Telefon. Du willst dich schon bewegen, aber du willst nicht so erlauben. Ich will mich nicht selber bewegen, wo wir da bei E-Mobilität werden, was mich immer noch beschäftigt. Da steelle ich mich drauf und fahre durch die Gegend und werde manchmal ruckartig, rede sich ja auch manchmal im Kreis. Aber du hast dich mittlerweile gut daran gewöhnt. Und dann supernervig tatsächlich, habe ich den, ich war erst stolz, weil er so ganz cool die Wohnung erkannt hat und so und diese Hindernisse als solche. Dann bin ich losgegangen, habe den alleine laufen lassen zum Saugen und Wischen und ich krieg so zehn Minuten, ich fahr auf dem Fahrrad, weg von der Wohnung, nach zehn Minuten Sonnen, ja, der Stolzler hat sich verfangen. Und dann sieht man halt auf dieser Karte, super krass jetzt den ganzen Weg, den er zurückgelegt hat, sieht man, wo, aber man sieht auch, wo das Problem begonnen hat und wo er jetzt ist und dann sieht man diesen ganzen weirden Weg dazwischen und es sah aus als hätte er einen riesen Blutbad veranstaltet. Im Endeffekt hat er sich nur in einer Pflanze verhangen und es war gar nicht so schlimm, er musste ja einfach die Pflanze, so eine Hängepflanze, musste er wieder rausziehen, aber es sah halt so, diese App hat mich so nervös gemacht, weil man sah halt diesen Weg, den er danach gefahren ist, wo man so denkt, ah, dann hat er noch die Lampe umgeworfen, dann ist er durch, weiß ich nicht, Öl, das Ölfass
hat er umgekippt, warum geht er da ran, warum steht's? Ja, und dann den Kamin einfach. Finde ich gut, aber ich finde, darf der Roboter selber entscheiden, wann er nach Hilfe ruft, als er sagt, okay, das schaffe ich, das schaffe ich, ich muss jetzt einfach nach geradeaus fahren, ich fahre jetzt einfach nach geradeaus, dann dreh ich mich zweimal und dann fahre ich nach links. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, das wird immer schlimmer, das wird schlimmer. Okay, okay, alles gut. Du rufst jetzt einfach Stefan an und Stefan kommt und rettet dich, okay? Die Wohnung in Flammen, drück den Knopf, ich drück jetzt den Knopf. Und bei dir so, und du so, oh Gott, vollidiot. Grossartig, dann gehen wir jetzt weiter mit Gefe Giacomo und natürlich die Geschichte, mein alter Ego, meine Rolle. Wie ist es da weitergegangen? Wir haben es einmal gehört, es war ein One-Off-Abenteuer, wir haben danach nie wieder was gehört. Ne, das war dann auch relativ bald vorbei, als die Gilde sich aufgelöst hat irgendwann. Das war ja mein World of Warcraft-Charakter, wo ich um meine soziale Angst zu überwinden im Voice-Com, also im Team-Speak, wo man sich dann so zusammen unterhält, habe ich eine Rolle angenommen, weil ich nicht ich selber sein wollte, weil ich dachte, es gibt mir die Möglichkeit, sozialer zu sein, indem ich einfach Giacomo spiele.
Und so ist diese Figur entstanden und aber auch relativ
bald dann auch wieder gestorben, als die Gilde
sich irgendwann aufgelöst hat. Und dann war es das.
Und seitdem, ja, ist die Person
weg. Giacomo ist
tot. Ich glaube, das war
ein großer Bestandteil des Erfolgs
dieser Geschichte liegt
daran. Ich finde es gut, dass wir so
Reinfahr-Promis
Nils Bogleberg Ah, Giacomo, daran erinnere ich mich auch noch, ja. Ich weiss noch, da habe ich den Podcast gehört und da habe ich gelacht, ja. Da kommt so Sylvie Mais. Ah ja, genau, die Giacomo-Geschichte hat mir besonders gefallen, weil jeder kennt es ja, man ist auf Partys und man fühlt sich nicht wohl oder sowas. Und dann diese grosse Freiheit, die man plötzlich hat.
Sie wird rausgefahren mit dem Satz, kommt Elton rein. Ja, manchmal wünsche ich mir auch ein Adiacomo. Okay, man hätte das nie gesehen, aber wie diese Chartshow-Countdowns. Ja, genau, die hundert besten Songs Songs. Einfach rein damit. er ha's weiter mit Hinter dem Mikrofon hat alles angefangen. Ja, cooles, erinnere ich mich immer noch sehr gerne zurück. Haben wir oft gesungen bei Live-Songs, haben wir das immer gesungen, am Ende noch, erinnerst du dich? I geht's weiter mit Intro, als kleine Hommage an natürlich die hunderten und aber hunderten und tausenden Intros, die eingesendet wurden, vielen, vielen Dank dafür, die natürlich auch immer sehr gut ankommen, hoffentlich. Jeff auf J, Jeff, natürlich haben wir gerade gehört, dein ehemaliger Kampfschiff, dein Kampfschiff, das untergegangen ist, leider. Die USS Jeff. Genau, mein ehemaliges Kampfschiff, ja, also sang und klanglos untergegangen, das war ein bescheuertes Kauf. Er hatte niemanden, gegen den er kämpfen konnte, ne? Er war ein Kampfschiff, aber hatte nie wirklich jemanden. Und ich stelle dir das nicht vor, also natürlich jeder von uns hat schon mal gedacht, ja jetzt ein Kampfschiff kaufen. Klar. Und dann hat man das da liegen in Holland, dieses Riesenkampfschiff. Ja, das ist halt, und dann die Munition und der Unterhalt, die Besatzung. Und der hinfahren und der, genau, und ich meine, Maintenance. Am Ende fährt man dann doch nicht so oft hin. Man fährt dann doch nicht so. Man findet dann doch nicht so viel Zeit. Was, da so ein Zerstörer liegen irgendwie auch in den Haar. Fragt alle mit diesem, genau, wenn die sich schon mal so einen 200 Meter dicken Pott Kampfschiff geholt haben, man macht es dann doch nicht. Und dann die Lizenzen, mein Gott, mit der Munition, hin und her, leuchte, okay. Du darfst nicht töten, mein Gott. So, und dann geht es weiter mit K, der Kleingeldeimer. Ja, heute tatsächlich wieder ein bisschen leichter geworden, denn ich habe 10, 20 Cent Münzen entnommen. Das heißt, aktuell ist er im Schwunde, allerdings immer noch ein absolut unbewegliches Objekt. Also ich glaube, eine absolute Immobilie, da rührt sich nichts. Die wahrscheinlich beste Wertanlage, die ich je gehabt habe in meinem Leben. Ich bin finanziell am Ende, sagen wir es so. Ich habe oft schon falsch investiert in meinem Leben. Wir erinnern uns an die Solaranleihen, die am Ende alle weg waren. Solaranlagenanleihen. Solaranleihen, ja, wo die irgendwann einfach bankrott gegangen sind und alles hat sich aufgelöst. Solaranleihen oder Solaranlagenanleihen? Anleihen. Man leiht der Firma Geld. Und dann sagt die, warum leist du mir Geld? Also Solaranlagenfirmenanleihen.
Du kürztest irgendwie so ab, als würdest du in die Sonnenkraft investieren. Auf eine Art machst du das ja.
Die Sonne hat eine unendliche Macht, Stefan. Unendliche Macht und hat tonbringende Gewalt. Sonnenstürme bedrohen die Erde seit Menschen denken.
Wirklich? Weiß ich die Erde seit Menschen denken.
Wirklich?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe so eine Angst vor Sonnenstürmen. Du nicht?
Nee, geht. Warum hast du Angst vor Sonnenstürmen? Weil es dann ganz heiß wird? Ich habe zu früh diese gruseligen Eimer in Abdallah Galileo folgen geguckt. Galileo folgen geguckt. Galileo! Und ich habe so vor, also ich habe Angst vor dem Bibelcode. Ich habe Angst vor jedem Bibelcode. Ja, ich habe keine Bibel mehr angerührt, keinen Bibelsong mehr gesungen. Ich habe Angst vor Sonnenstürmen. Ja, ich habe Angst vor fucking Bigfoot. Ich habe Angst, dass der Mond auf die Erde runterfällt, Wie ein Stein. Ja. Und wir auch nicht rechtzeitig reagieren. Wir würden das gar nicht mitkriegen. Das wäre alles. Glaubst du, du könntest noch einen Schrei ausstoßen, bevor der Mond auf dich stürzt? Du hast du gefragt, du könntest es verhindern. Ja. Nee, das würde ich gar nicht fragen. Das wäre alles. Das ist Quatsch. L, Leckermate. Wie ist es da weitergegangen? Du wohnst gar nicht mehr da, oder? Wohnst du noch an dem Leckermate? Doch, doch, doch, doch, aber ich kaufe jetzt woanders Mate und habe immer mein Kleingeld perfekt passend dabei. Und mittlerweile bin ich mit dem anderen Geschäft so weit auf Vertrauensbasis, dass meine 10, 20 Cent Münzen nicht mehr nachgezählt werden. Ich reiche den Stapel zwischen Daumen und Zeigefinger, gepresst mit einer Geldklammer, die man in der Hand darstellt, überreiche ich diese zehn Münzen und die werden in die Kasse gelegt, nicht nachgezählt. Für jemanden mit extremen Sozialängsten finde ich es erstaunlich, dass du ihn mit maximal viel Kleingeld zahlen willst. Ja, ich will ja den, also ich will ja, gut, dann gehen wir nochmal Buchstaben zurück, zu K, Kleingeldeimer. So, anscheinend hast du es nicht verstanden. Ich muss ja den Eimer irgendwie auflösen, da ist ja unfassbar viel Kleingeld drin, der muss ja weg. Und ich dachte, entweder ich bringe es irgendwann zur Bank, oder ich gebe es langsam aus. Aber einmal zur Bank gehen, oder, weiss nicht, 523 soziale schlimme Interaktionen, weil du mit zehn Centstücken zahlst. Ja gut, ich verstehe schon. M, Moloch, unsere Hausaufgabe, ihr solltet Moloch irgendwo unterbringen. Viele kriegen immer noch schöne Nachrichten, wie Leute Moloch untergebracht haben, unterbringen, auch paar Prominente haben Moloch heruntergebracht. Genau, und wir gehen einfach davon aus, dass sie das tun, weil sie Podcast-Ufo-Hörer sind. Also egal, ob jetzt irgendwie Kylie Minogue oder im Nobelpreisträger das Wort Moloch benutzen, wir denken, ah, einer von uns, einer von uns, N für Nolens Wohlenz. Ähnlich, ähnlich. Nolens Wohlenz, so habe ich auch gesagt. Du wolltest mal schlau wirken, glaube ich, und hast Nolens Wohlenz gesagt. Schlau wirken. Ich habe gesagt, Nullens-Wohlenz solltet ihr häufiger mal unterbringen. Es ist aber Nolens, Wohlenz nicht so einfach, das unterzubringen. Das ist die lateinische Version von wohl oder übel. Okay, O für die Ohrenkamera. Ja, tatsächlich, ich habe mittlerweile, ich glaube, das weiss ich gar nicht, ob ich das schon mal erzählt habe, ich habe mittlerweile schon Upgrade bekommen. Ich habe die Ohrenkamera gekauft, das ist so ein winziger kleiner Metallstab mit Griff, wo eine Kamera und Licht vorne dran ist, so dass man in sein Ohr reinleuchten kann und dann mit so einem Schaber aus so einer First-Person-Perspektive, dass sie schön einfach den Schleim, die verkrusteten wirklich Bernsteinhöhlen da rausziehen kann. Und das war erst ein großes Problem, weil weil meine Ohren dadurch wund geworden sind und Gehörgangsentzündungen all diese Späße, bis ich es irgendwann nicht mehr so benutzt habe. Das erzählst du immer nicht. Du erzählst dir immer nur lustig rum, wie du deine Körperöffnungen erforscht. Ja, das Ding ist natürlich das. Also das Problem ist, dass manchmal kann man Ohr und Schmalz am Trommelfell haben. Und das Trommelfell ist natürlich sehr empfindlich und das ist schmerzhaft. Und ich habe es bis zuletzt nicht richtig sehen können, ob das der Fall ist oder nicht. Weil ich habe nie gecheckt, ist das das Trommelfell oder nicht. So, und das Problem ist ja, du hast ja ... Man kann sich ja auch immer keine Vorstellung vom Trommelfell. Nee, du weißt es nicht, du checkst es nicht. Und am Ende war es das Trommelfell? So, und jetzt dachte ich mir, bei meiner ersten Ohrenkamera hatte ich unten nur so eine Art Gabel, mit der man dann halt so schaben und ziehen kann. Aber je weiter du das ins Ohr reinsteckst, desto geringer wird ja dein Spielraum, weil du kannst es ja nicht mehr so weit bewegen, weil du hast ja den ganzen Stiel im Ohrstecken. Das heisst, wenn du dir jetzt vorstellst, du hast diesen Löffel und gehst gegen eine Wand hinten,
dann kannst du nicht wirklich eine
Kraft entwickeln, die nach hinten zieht,
sondern du schiebst es nur von links nach rechts,
weil du kannst es nicht packen.
In meiner Vorstellung ist ja auch, glaube ich,
zu Recht der Gehörgang nicht
ein glatter, gerader Tunnel,
sondern so ein
Ding. Ja, ein bisschen gekrümmelt.
Du kannst eh schon froh sein, dass du ganz am Ende angekommen bist, und dann kannst du ja nicht rumpröckeln. Warum bei dem, was ich jetzt sage? Ja, weil es so dumm ist, weil es so unnötig ist. Das Ding ist, wenn du einmal diesen Bereich betreten hast, wenn du einmal in dein Ohr geblickt hast, dann ist das einfach ein Raum. Dann ist das wie, dann denkst du dir, was ist da los, wie geht's dem gerade so? Du kannst dich da hin zu nicht mehr das ist auch eine art rückzugsraum wenn ihr in so einem cubicle büro seid so ganz im grossraumbüro mit ganz vielen leuten und die haben braucht man raum zum zurückziehen ja da habe ich so eine ohrenkamera zieht euch in euch zurück und ist es wirklich unfassbar ekelhaft also ihr habt keine vorstellung egal wie ihr euch jetzt gerade zusammenzieht, ist es noch ekliger. Es ist so eklig, dass ich es Max Bierhals
geschickt habe, unserem ehemaligen Kollegen,
der gesagt hat, er hätte Lust, eine Late-Night-Show
in einem Ohr zu machen. Also dass
man, wenn wir schon die Kamera da haben, dass dann so ein
kleiner Mann im Ohr sitzt, der eine Late-Night-Show
macht, fand ich sehr gut, weil die Kamera
ist auch nicht schlecht. Also ich glaube... Kann man nicht
doof gesagt einen Greenscreen aufstellen
im Ohr, einen kleinen Greenscreen?
Es reicht ja so ein
kleines grünes Partikel.
Dann machst du die Kamera rein. Ich glaube, es ist ein einfacher
Aber ich, doof gesagt, einen Greenscreen aufstellen im Ohr, einen kleinen Greenscreen, es reicht ja so ein kleines grünes Partikel, dann machst du die Kamera rein. Ich glaube, es ist einfacher, den Moderator vor Greenscreen zu setzen und dann ins Ohr reinzubringen. Genau, auf die grüne Stelle im Ohr, meine ich. Aber dann brauchst du kein grünes im Ohr, ne? Ja, aber ich finde es schon trotzdem schön, dir was ins Ohr zu. Du willst einfach dir was grünes ins Ohr stecken. Also, auf jeden Fall die Problematik, nur damit es verstanden ist, du hast den mit dem Löffel, löffel gehst du ja im 90 grad winkel gegen die hinterwand des ohrs und kannst nicht so richtig was rausziehen weil du hast keine kraft nach hinten dann habe ich lange gesucht und gegoogelt und habe tatsächlich eine ein upgrade gefunden für die uhrenkamera die nicht nur einen löffel hat sondern eine zange also ein kirmes wie ein kirmes werkzeug genau so ein klemmer und den gab es aber nur in China. Nur in China gab es den und dann habe ich den bestellt für nicht allzu wenig Geld.
Und dann kam der an und du hast dann tatsächlich am Griff hast du noch so einen Drücker, wo du diese kleine Zange auf und zumachen kannst. Machst du das bei Twitch die ganze Zeit? Ja.
Ist das, was du bei Twitch machst? Ja, das ist so.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, danke an den Pimmelgeneral für den Sub, danke.
Vielen Dank. Au, au, au, au, au, au, au, au.
Cool, Joy63, vier Monate dabei, vielen Dank. Danke für den Rate an Feebly-General für den Sub, danke. Au, au, au, au, au, au, au, au, au, au, au, joy63, vier Monate dabei, vielen Dank, danke für den Raid an Feeblee, dankeschön, au, au, a, a, a, hier nochmal für die Raider, wir sind gerade, was ihr gerade seht, ist keine Tropfsteinhülle, ist mein Ohr, sondern mein Innenohr. Und dann habe ich diese Zange gemacht und kurz, um es kurz zu machen, es funktioniert überhaupt nicht, weil ich traue mich am Ende nicht da zuzupacken, weil ich nicht weiss, ob ich am Ende mein Trommelfell rausziehe und um ganz ehrlich zu sein, ich habe jetzt auch schon seit ein paar Wochen dieses,, ein Community-Projekt. Es ist eine Wiki-artige, also ein Wiki für unsere ganze Lore. Ja, kann man auch supergut suchen. Wir haben im Reddit ganz viele Posts, was war denn die Folge mit dem, was war denn die Folge mit dem. Könnt ihr gerne eine Pufopedia suchen, aber auch der Hinweis, wir brauchen immer noch Leute, die die Pufopedia befüllen. Also gerade zu den Folgen, die einzuspeisen. Falls ihr also sagt, gerade zur Weihnachtszeit, ach ich ich hab Zeit, ich will was machen, ist ein cooles Community-Projekt. Ich dachte zwar, es wird Phase bei P, aber am Ende wurde es die Puffopedia, was natürlich auch heißt, dass die Community hinter der Puffopedia steht, was uns sehr freut. Geht da mal hin und klickt euch durch und befüllt es. Super lustige auch, ganz, ganz tolle, lustige Beiträge, die fantastisch toll geschrieben sind von sehr lustigen Menschen von euch, vielen Dank dafür. Q, keine Erinnerung an Q. Q ist das Wort Kö, Q-U-E-U-E. Haben wir mal Billard gespielt, hatten wir mal eine Billard-Folge? Q, haben wir darüber geredet? Nee, haben wir darüber lustig gemacht, wie das Wort geschrieben wird, mit glaube, wir haben drüber gelacht, dass es so viele
Ue, Ue, Ue drin sind.
Ruheabteil, R,
haben wir da jemals drüber gesprochen?
Ruheabteil? Sagt mir gar nichts.
Was ist das?
Ich glaube, das ist, wenn man
die Kopfhörer auf Noise-Canceling
schaltet. Ach so, okay.
Keine Ahnung.
Es ist natürlich Smeesma, unser Running-, den wir lange etablieren wollten, der nicht angekommen ist, leider. So ein whatever, also so ein englisches whatever. Das ist so ein bisschen yada yada, es war so, ja mein Gott, dann nehmen wir da halt mit, Koffer, Zahnbürste, Smeesma, das ist halt so, halt irgendwas. Also wir haben Wort erfunden für etwas, wo es schon neunzehn verschiedene Wege gibt, das zu sagen. Und wir haben das wirklich mit Gewalt versucht, der Gesellschaft aufzupfropfen, dieses Wort. Und es hat nicht funktioniert, es ist abgeperlt. T, Thais, unsere liebe Schülerpraktikantin Thais, Gott hab sie selig, inzwischen ist sie volljährig. Sie ist nicht tot. Inzwischen ist sie, glaube ich, Nobelpreisträgerin, Investigativjournalistin. Es ist natürlich... Grüße gehen raus. Sie ist nicht tot, Stefan. Von da oben wird sie auf uns... Stefan, sie wird uns... Ja, sie ist jetzt in den dritten Stock gezogen. Sie ist jetzt an einem besseren Ort. Ja, sie lebt jetzt in einer anderen Stadt. Sie ist nicht tot. Hoffen wir zumindest nicht, denn sie ist abgetaut, sie ist undercover. Sie ist ja aktuell immer noch an dem Fall dran mit dem Trinkgeld im Dominos.
Stefan hatte eine Whistleblower-Nachricht bekommen von einem verzweifelten Mitarbeiter von Dominos, der meinte, er würde kein Trinkgeld kriegen von dem Trinkgeld, das man in der App dann sozusagen gibt. Und wir haben Thais darauf angesetzt und bis heute ist sie im Untergrund. Also ihr müsst euch das vorstellen, ich habe das vergessen, dass wir diesen Zugriff machen mit sie hat dann diese Stelle bekommen, diese Praktikantenstelle bei Dominos. Es war irgendwie so ein Sonntag, keine Ahnung. Dann habe ich das vergessen, dass es kam, dieser Tag und war schlicht vorbereitet und so. Sie kam dann an, dann klingelt Stefan, jetzt geht los, Dominos Outfit, so, ich habe keine Pizza bestellt, ach Thais, du bist es, dazu wärst tot, sie hat gesagt, sie ist nicht tot, hä, ich bin nicht tot, flog jemand auch, hä, sie ist nicht tot, ich wohne bei dir, warum sagst du nicht, dass ich tot bin, so, dann, wir wurden nebeneinander, wir sind nebeneinander, standen, also spärlich bekleidet, Haare zerbrochen, alles sah nach Sex, roch und sah aus nach Sex, wir haben die Tür aufgemacht, so, dann war Thais da, wo ist der Van, ich so, das ist welcher Van, hä, was für? Nee, der Überwachung. Sagst du nicht erstmal Hallo? Der Surveillance-Van. Sagst du erstmal Hallo? Sag die Jugend, wo ist der Van? Ist das so was irgendwie, bin ich nicht Van genug für dich oder was? Und dann wir so, ach, die Vans, meinst du die Schuhe Vans, die man jetzt wieder trägt? Wir so, hi, wo ist der Van? So getan, als wäre das eine casual Begrüßung, sie hat gesagt, nein, Leute, reiss euch zusammen, zieht euch bitte was an, nee, der Van, der Surveillance-Van für mein Domino. Genau. Wir haben uns schnell so einen Miles-Transporter gemietet. Wir haben uns schnell was angezogen, was übergeworfen, ganz schnell. So schnell sind diese Walkie-Talkies, die ich habe, drei Stück, wie jeder, sie kommen in sets of three, dann haben wir uns die genommen, sind zu Dominos gefahren, sie ist rein hat den Job angefangen, die Walkie-Talkies haben nicht funktioniert, weil ich die Batterien wie gesagt, wir haben es vergessen, beide ja, wir haben es einfach nicht mehr auf dem Schirm gehabt, so richtig Batterien gingen nicht, und dann haben wir sie verloren, und dann wurde uns ein bisschen haben wir gewartet, und dann ist die Frage, wie lange wartet man in solchen Fällen, 20, 30 Minuten und dann haben wir das Interesse verloren, seitdem ist sie bei Domino. Genau, sie arbeitet jeden Tag eine komplette Schicht und also wir wissen nicht genau, ob es ihr gut gefällt, weil wir wie gesagt leider keinen Kontakt mehr haben, weil das Walkie-Talkie, wir wissen nicht, ob sie das Walkie-Talkie noch hat. Selbst wenn, also ich glaube nicht, dass es mehr funktioniert, haben wir unsere noch, ich habe den mir weggeschmissen. Ich habe es irgendwo hingelegt, ich habe es weggeschmissen. Ich habe es doch nicht weggeschmissen. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also ich sage mal so, wir sind noch an dem Fall dran. Dominos, hütet euch! Ich will nur wissen und euch sagen, Thais wacht über euch. Egal, wer ihr seid. Sie wacht über euch von da oben, sie guckt zu und ihr braucht euch keine Augen machen. Sie la, sie ist nicht tot. Sie lauert, sie kann in jedem Busch,
in jeder Hecke kann sie lauern und egal
was ihr anstehlt, jeden Tag,
es kann gut sein, dass Thais euch
beobachtet, denn sie ist da draussen.
Denn sie wacht von oben bei Gott
über euch. Nicht tot, also auf U geht's
weiter mit
Wappadabababa, Wappadabada,
Dinglelingleling,
die das Podcast-Ufo, Entschuldigung, Uldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung. Ja, das ist unser beliebter Jingle, der anscheinend Wappadabada anfängt. Hätte ich anders geschrieben. Wie hättest du es geschrieben? W. Wappadabadab, also das englische Wappadabab, finde ich aber auch gut in U, aber jetzt ist es auf jeden Fall offiziell Wappadabba.arabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabarabar um das tatsächlich nachzuspielen. Also falls ihr gerade ein neues Instrument lernt und noch nicht wisst, was ist ein einfacher Song, mit dem ich anfangen kann,
Querflöte, Banjo, Bongo, dann könnt ihr das gerne spielen.
Das Podcast-Ufo-Entschuldigungs-Intro-Musik.
V ist der Vorderfuss-Entlastungs-Schuh.
Ja, ich habe mir ein Zeh gebrochen vor langer Zeit und musste lange mit dem Vorderfuss-Entlastungs-Schuh durch die Gegend laufen.
Und dieses Wort sucht mich immer noch heim. Tatsächlich habe ich den noch. Ich besitze ihn noch. Das Problem ist, den sieht man halt selten an. Ich finde das so ein schönes Wort. Vorderfussentlastungsschuh. Es reimt sich nämlich auch. Vorderfussentlastungsschuh. Ja. Also so unrein, aber es ist ein schönes Wort. Es klingt auf jeden Fall schön. Es ist der rechte Schuh. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man da unterscheidet. Letztens hatte ich wieder überlegt, habe ich mir nicht ein C gebrochen, hätte ich es vielleicht wieder benutzen können, aber aktuell ist er unbenutzt, falls ihn jemand braucht, meldet euch. Es ist ein rechter Vorderfuss-Entlastungsschuh in der Größe, was hast du, 38? 43, und ich sag mal so, er hat schon ordentlich meinen Vorderfuss entlastet. Also klar, ihr fragt jetzt, Moment mal, wenn du den Vorderfuß entlastest, wo geht die Last hin? Der Schuh trägt sie. Genau, also die Last muss ja immer, die Last ist ja gleich. Und deswegen nochmal, gerade zu Weihnachten lohnt es sich, auf die zu gucken, die uns die Last nehmen, die die Gesellschaft tragen. Und besonders finde ich, fallen immer hinten rüber die Vorderfuussentlastungsschuhe, Schuhe, Schiechen.
Die so viel Last auf sich nehmen, jedes Jahr.
Denn wir als Gesellschaft würden nicht funktionieren, wenn nicht der Vorderfussentlastungsschuh uns entlasten würde.
Im modernen Menschen viel Last lastet auf ihm, viele Probleme sind vor uns, wir stehen an einem Punkt, wo wir nicht wissen, wo geht die Welt hin.
Dann Thais hört uns zu und ist ... Sie lebt. Schreibt das hoffentlich. Das sind diese Zeichen, wo ich denke, sie ist bei mir. Also sie ist bei uns noch, Flo und Dean. W ist die Worst Bird Production. Ein ... May I say? Nächstes Jahr weg. Lassen wir nächstes Jahr?
Ja, vielleicht auch das. Ein Running Gag, wo man nicht weiss, wo er hinführt.
Vielleicht ist er noch irgendwann sinnvoll.
Ich weiss auch nicht mehr ganz genau, was da die Geschichte war.
Wir wollten die Domain haben, Worst Bird.
Und da gab es ja diese Geschichte mit den 50 Euro, dass wir versucht haben, die Domain zu kaufen.
Und am Ende ... Aber ich glaube, Worst Bird haben wir nicht bekommen, glaube ich.
Ich weiss gar nicht, was Worst Bird heutzutage ist. Übrigens, Grüße gehen raus an den, weil ich verkaufe gerade sehr viele Sachen bei Ebay, aufgrund, weil das mein Elternhaus, weil mein Elternhaus ja bald weg ist und ich das ausräume gerade. und da verkaufe ich viel bei Ebay.
Grüße gehen raus an diejenigen, ich weiß nicht, ob das inzwischen alle machen oder ob es ein Hörer war, aber ich habe einen alten Schlafcouch verkaufen wollen für 100 Euro und dann ist Gegenangebot 50, ich habe gesagt, wir wollen uns in der Mitte treffen, 70 angeboten und er hat gesagt, hab nur 50. Und ich musste ganz laut, laut loslachen, weil ich dachte, oh nein, jetzt verfolgen uns unsere Tricks hier. Auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite natürlich tolle Taktik, auf der anderen Seite kann es auch einfach geflügelt sein inzwischen. Ja, ja, es ist eine gute Taktik. Ich hoffe, ich habe damit nicht das Verhandeln im Allgemeinen, die Kunst des Verhandelns zerstört, aber ich glaube, ich habe eine ganze Menge Leute viel Geld gespart. Dann jetzt kommen wir natürlich zu den drei schwierigen Buchstaben XYZ. Ich würde sagen, bei W hätte ich die WC-Ente mir gewünscht. WC-Ente, WC-Schwan, ja, stimmt. Wo wir bemerkt haben, dass die WC-Ente eigentlich ein Schwan ist und uns beschwert haben, beschwarnt haben. Und wir in einem langen Briefverkehr mit Johnson & Johnson gelandet waren und uns beschimpft haben. Ja, jetzt wird es natürlich sehr, sehr schwer, jetzt kommen wir zum X-Expect, eine alte Band gibt es nicht mehr. Auch da jetzt die Frage, ich habe gesagt, wir hatten in meinem ehemaligen Elternhaus haben wir geprobt und da hatten wir jetzt noch diese grossen Banner von unseren Bands. Ach was, aber die kannst du doch irgendwo gewinnbringend verkaufen, oder? Die originale Banner von X-Pack. Ja, X-Pack. Es gibt so viele X-Pack-Fans da draußen. Eine Band, die sich aufgelöst hat, noch alte Banner und Merch, das ist doch Gold wert. Aber X-Pack war ja unsere erste sehr unerfolgreiche Kackband. Und mit der haben wir halt auf Weihnachtsmärkten und sowas gespielt. Und meine Mom hat jeden Zeitungsartikel aufgehoben, der jemals über X-Pack und die andere Band geschrieben wurde. Und es war so krass, wie leicht man in, zumindest bei uns, in der Lokalzeitung gelandet ist. Also wirklich so ein ordnerer Zeigungsartikel über diese Band. Ey, ihr wart nicht schlecht, ihr wart echt gut, ihr wart echt gut, aber hatte, hatte Expect auch eigene Songs oder nur Cover? Expect hatte die ersten eigenen Songs dann. Okay, was waren da so für Tracks dabei? Chill out with our music, come on and sing with us, don't be a bird brain and prefer to feel the bass. Don't be a bird brain? Ja. Wie gut ist das denn? Was ist denn Don't be a bird brain? Ich weiss nicht, ich habe das in der Gibt. Worum ging es in einem Song? Chill out with our music, come on and sing with us. Ach, das ist alles ein Titel? Ja. Das ist ein Song. Ich dachte, da sind mehrere Songs. Chill out with our music, come on and sing with us, don't be a bird brain and prefer to feel the bass. Also das macht auch keinen Sinn. Aber weißt du, wie alt war er wieder? Zwölf oder so, dreizehn, vierzehn? Ah, die Sprache ächzt unter deinem Druck einfach. Es ist nicht, das ist ja. Ah, die Sprache im Schraubstock. Englisch war für uns sozusagen ein Mittel, was wie so ein Sandkasten war. Denn wenn du die Regeln nicht kennst, kannst du machen, was du willst. Es ist so, als würde man Gravitation ausschalten als Element, was gegen dich wirkt, und du hast so ein Sandkastenprojekt. Weil die Sprache, wir hatten die Regeln nicht der Sprache, dass es auch Bass heisst und nicht Bass. Aber es ist eine Freiheit, die du nicht mehr hast heute. Du bist natürlich heute, es ist leichter zu reimen, wenn man nicht so wirklich Ahnung hat, wie Sachen ausgesprochen werden. Wie Sprachen funktionieren, es ist viel leichter zu reimen und Songtext zu schreiben. Also Expect auf x, y natürlich der schwerste Buchstabe, würde ich sagen. Da hat sich das Podcast UFO Community entschieden für Yes And, die Grundregel von Improv Comedy. Und haben wir glaube ich nie so wirklich besprochen hier im Podcast, aber wir machen ja seit einiger Zeit Improv Comedy hier in Kölle und versuchen das nächstes Jahr auch ein bisschen grösser aufzunehmen. Und dann bald auch in Hamburg. Bald auch in Hamburg, ja. Seid gespannt, folgt dem Instagram-Account Tietz und Will. Es hat nichts mit das Podcast-Uvo zu tun, wir machen was ganz anderes. Es ist kein Podcast, es ist nicht das Podcast-Uvo. Es ist kein das Podcast-Uvo-Podcast-Projekt-Projekt. Nein. Es ist ein anderes Projekt. Tietz und Will ist ein anderes Projekt. Wir machen da Improv-Comedy. Genau, und es ist auch komplett anders, weil Podcast-Uwe machen Stefan Tietze und Florentin Will. Und Tietze und Will sind Florentin Will und Stefan Tietze. Ja, machen wir auch wir. Ja, aber es ist trotzdem was komplett anderes. Aber es ist kein gutes Distinktionsmerkmal. Ja, aber es sind beides wir. Wenn wir zusammen Baumarkt aufmachen, ist es ja auch kein Podcast. Also das ist ja Quatsch. Ja, ist doch denn von uns. Ja, aber es ist ein anderer Stefan und ein anderer Florentin. Es ist unterschiedliche Dinge. Das stimmt wirklich. Das stimmt wirklich. Wir machen da zotige Witze die ganze Zeit. Oh ja. Z ist offiziell noch nicht festgelegt zum aktuellen Punkt der Aufnahme, aber aktuell, wir können das ja so ein bisschen nicht verfolgen, gibt es hier vieles, Zimbabwe, Zibulino wurde genannt, Zwitsche Duri, also ihr könnt euch da auch alle Posts nochmal durchgucken. Die Zentrale, die Zentrale, Podcast, sehr schöne Folgen. Und zwei Euro vierzig. Hat aktuell am meisten Votes, zwei Euro vierzig für die Brezelfolge. Zibulino, aber es war nicht in diesem Podcast. Ja, Zibulino war der Gute Arbeit im Pro Podcast, GutePodcast, Gute-Arbeit-Impro, gab es auch mittlerweile tatsächlich vollständig indiziert und nicht mehr erhältlich.
Weil das ZDF, kann man auch mal sagen, die scheisse Eigen-Soundcloud-Rechnung, was sind das, fucking 70 Euro im Jahr, nicht zahlen wollte mehr. Das ist fucking ZDF. Und dann gu man, guckt man kurz bei Wetten das rein,
Pyro und Thomas Gottschalk
fährt auf Baggern
herum, auf Baggern, die auf Baggern,
die auf dem Mars fahren, herum
und sie wollen die scheiß Soundcloud-Rechnung nicht
zahlen. Tja. Für gute Arbeit im Pro.
Ist aber vielleicht rückblickend gar nicht so
schlecht. Also ich weiß gar nicht, welchen Punkte ich gerade machen will.
Ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht.
Ne, auf jeden Fall nicht mehr verfügbar.
Was aber auf jeden Fall verfügbar ist, ist die nächste Folge in einer Woche.
Keine Angst, wir bringen in der nächsten Woche die nächste Folge raus.
Falls ihr sagt, was passiert jetzt, wie geht's weiter, keine Sorge, nächste Woche geht's weiter.
Und bis dahin wünschen wir euch eine ganz tolle Vorweihnachtszeit, eine besinnliche Zeit.
Kommt runter, kommt verdammt noch mal runter.
Ey, bitte, ey, kommt runter, kommt alle mal runter.
Und nicht ausrutschen, macht's gut. Wir sehen uns nächste Bitte, kommt mal runter. Kommt alle mal runter.
Und nicht ausrutschen, macht's gut. Wir sehen uns nächste Woche, wenn Stefan Tietze erneut sagt.
Hi, sage ich dann wieder. Wenn es wieder heisst, hallo.
Ich freue mich drauf. Stefan, das war meine Ehre, bis nächste Woche.
Ciao, macht's gut, tschüss, wir heben ab jetzt!